i might text y'all hey guys halloween
party my house
2 p.m two hours go by no one says
anything
but man [ __ ] y'all
he said man [ __ ] y'all y'all the thing
that got me was the fact that he said no
pressure but you gotta know if you're
coming over to a guy's party man
we got kids and [ __ ] he said what
happened to you in high school when no
one came or something no
you know you just got a plan dude hi
guys i'm having a little party
a lot of planning goes into it man now
we're going to pull up
all right be cool man all right bro yeah
like
project x don't get your big ass in the
jump castle either man it's for the kids
ain't trying to get no don't be doing
back flipping
[ __ ] for these kids restrictions i love
a good joke castle you can make it in
the jungle yeah you and me might be too
big yeah too big
you i'm a flip i mean have you ever done
a football i flipped off a trampoline
but i can't flip off ground now
okay i need some wind pretty easy yeah i
need some gusts have you ever like
flipped your body
yeah i used to do gymnastics yeah
as a grown man though as a grown man i
did it with uh you just started no i i
did it i did it for uh
because the the best fighter in the
world gsp used to do it and he told me
it's real good for him
yeah so we should go to gymnastics like
twice a week oh dude
so we used to do backflips in the foam
pit yeah i can't do it on land yeah i
could do it into the foam pit oh see
that's good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
do like cartwheels and [ __ ]
and they had us like on the bars and
stuff lsu
has banned obj from all facilities for
the next two years because he gave out
100
bills to uh the players
oh you can't do that no you can't give
players money
really man louisiana's so strict who
snitched that out
it's a hundred dollars on camera it's on
camera it's a hundred dollars i know
what's funny is they give like a hundred
dollars it's gonna do anything but
they're giving them cash and then that
night lsu
probably made i don't know 120 million
bucks thank you for the for the for the
game
really yeah so they make money when a
team wins a championship yeah bcs
championship you made
bang yeah does the coach make oh yeah i
think
everybody hates me and everybody except
for the players
yeah you see the players you see how
rigged the system is come on man
really come on man it's bad it's bad
they don't give a
what so what do they give these besides
what a scholarship they're saying
educational peep game what if you like a
highlight
but meanwhile they help these
[ __ ] they make them take
communications
as majors yeah they said usually free
education but imagine you get hurt
and you mess up your knee and you was on
a full ride they don't pay for that yeah
they do they do cover it oh well then
what about your
example well yeah terrible example
terrible
you also can't major in whatever you
want right because there are only like a
certain section of classes you can take
no you can but they really they put they
basically give you you're like
i thought you were the biggest oh they
like set up everything for you
oh well you didn't take they missed zero
but these scouts they
started money like look at uh jerseys
buying jerseys
like this yeah they buy yeah they buy
the jerseys but but they could
now i think certain guys get percentage
of the jersey sales but again it's not
like life-changing
zion people bought manager i mean the
guy he was in duke he went to duke in
order for him to go
to his agent gave him two it gave the
dad 200 grand and a house
and now he's waiting reggie bush got
gifts too yeah so it's like
that's far like i think that happens but
it's [ __ ] up they have to go under the
table if you find out
you're ineligible like reggie bush lost
his heisman trophy hey rick pitino was
giving him uh
strippers oh yeah shout out shout out to
cincinnati
no uh kentucky louisville louisville
louisville there it is
the red and black my bad yeah what else
you got oh my lsu
ask your 60 year old 68 year old side
piece
she's still working on the back of the
way back in okay okay
you're 68 year old back in the day side
piece yeah
how many bad guys she's been through
because she's not a good guy she
wouldn't be
okay [ __ ] around with 24 year olds or
whatever you were yeah well it's 26.
and now listen let's get that out of the
way she had
she had bad experiences yes but let me
just let me relax
yes
wait for me to get my [ __ ] together
first okay you don't understand bad guys
you good guys right y'all y'all y'all
are predicated like y'all have a focus
on
like repetition like you have your focus
you're driven
you're straight forward you're a good
guy i am okay
bad guys we're a hat we're i'm not a bad
guy by the way queen i'm just standing
in my back
so look but you could be a bad guy back
in the day now i say mean bad guy i mean
like
you know talking are you talking [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah exactly looking around
yeah
i don't mean like a bad person like
killing people stealing money no and
that
and by the way when we say bad guy we
talking about like the characteristics
bad boy bad boy yeah bad boy we should
say that a bad boy is like they can't
like you know cheat on women disrespect
women yeah but never get physical
i don't get that no i was a player
because i realized that
one woman couldn't satisfy me all right
and that's that's naturally you were
young
i was young and and i was a bad boy but
i didn't
understand like what how that that
affected these women these women give
their all in relationships haven't you
heard this song by john mayer
daughters no i didn't know so when i had
something yeah it's a great [ __ ] song
listen to that song
that's you [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry i'm a
good guy and i was getting rejected when
i was younger
because i was such a good guy i'll start
a phone i wrote a love album for a girl
seven great songs seven
yeah on my guitar love to hear it here's
the no i'm not gonna [ __ ] up
john mayer has gone through so many
girls i don't know if he's like a good
guy
i'm not talking about i'm not talking
about john mayer i'm talking about the
song
he wrote okay i know but but like you
gotta take it who's writing it why is he
writing okay now we got to go that far
no but we'll
talk about the message yeah but if it's
a b but if the message is coming from
him it's like you know
i know a girl she puts the color inside
of my world
she's just amazed where all of the walls
and continually change and i've been
done all i can
to stand on her steps with my heart my
hands okay
now i'm starting to see maybe he's going
to do nothing this isn't a rabbit it's
got
maybe it's got nothing to do with me
fathers be good to your daughters
i don't have a loved one but that's it's
just it's just about
but bad boys it's like jared leto
writing that you're like what you [ __ ]
everything in the world
exactly serious
that's the only part though because he
does he's such as all these chicks he
had so much
and that's and he was a bad boy i hope
we can jam one day yeah
i do you know what we call that [ __ ]
great that's a hypocrite
okay listen you've gone right i'm just
bringing it out
okay but i'm saying everyone would you
rather me wrote write that down no
i wasn't that clever i'd feel better
about it you would feel better about it
i'm taking more
serious come on hey i i can't stand when
he sings that song
that song oh daughters be good
john there you called him a cornball oh
yeah
the other crunchy thing is when he goes
in your bubble gum tongue
god dude last cornball
listen okay my point is yeah back but
bad guys listen so he may know that
that uh hey there delilah there's
another one
yeah [ __ ] that song get [ __ ] cooler
man yeah i hate that that's on cornball
as [ __ ] hashtag cornballs
yeah you know that's that coin hashtag
cornballs haters delilah
but i you don't respect the message
it depends who it's coming from yeah
well i don't know those dudes
plain yt's by the way he was writing
about his friend's girl
so he had a crush on his friend's girl
or something so it's not good damn why
do these dudes jump into dumb situations
like that
what do you know r kelly wrote uh
a michael jackson song when he was
thinking about a high school girl
you're not you're not alone you know
damn what i'm talking about yeah that's
a great
that was that's a great song but r kelly
wrote it because
you like kelly's messages i love his
music oh here's some jams but
like we know all right all right you got
you proved your [ __ ] yeah
i honestly feel that chick-fil-a is a
little bit for me a little overrated man
i love the sauce though the chick-fil-a
sauce is great whatever dude
why would you say that yeah yeah
[ __ ] believe we're sitting here
talking all right
we had a moment
what fast food do you like well okay for
chicken mcnuggets
no no just in general like what's your
go-to fast food place i don't know
maybe shake shack i love this shake
shack i love it
now shake shack jack-in-the-box tacos
i think they're great next next yeah
that's for telly cafe that's where i got
the biscuits you used to be 300 pounds
how dare that right
wait so would you rather have chicken
nuggets or chick-fil-a nuggets
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a
really [ __ ] okay never mind he gonna try
to come at us with something
my fat ass would do i would get my
nuggets from chick-fil-a and then the
sweet and sour sauce from mcdonald's dip
them in that
that's so funny i would get my nuggets
from mcdonald's and get chick-fil-a
sauce
that's what i would do sounds completely
opposite and the sweet shower is great
too
ice is [ __ ] all right that's what else
you got you can't get this where do you
even get that outfit from
what poor person did you jack their
entire
work outfit from i did jack i didn't do
anything i don't i don't want to say
their names for legal reasons
now because you know they can get faster
your legs is different what do you mean
are they bigger right
you and john jones have the same legs
damn bro i've never really like full on
because you're always in pants and [ __ ]
you're talking like you could tell you
got little legs
don't say that like these shoulders why
are your calves bigger than your thighs
yeah we're like what the hell wait hold
on wait what do we just
never notice your legs though they still
don't want some of mine no
no don't do that don't breathe you want
some of my thoughts
i've seen you guys look like my drawers
we can help you out bro
i didn't realize they were like that you
look like you've been in a wheelchair
since you were 18.
that's [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
i came here cause i thought it was
halloween episode
and i went all in and i put lotion on my
legs your costume should have been
bigger legs brother
you sure i should have dressed up as a
calf muscle that's what you thought
no because you know cause i didn't first
thought was a you look like you look
like lieutenant dan from forest gum
but decide just to start walking like
yeah you got lieutenant dead legs
so you said if i get up right now i
remind you lieutenant dan that's what
you say
if i get up right now everybody okay
[ __ ] it
damn it i did a lot of squats don't do
that i did a lot of calf raises because
i
knew my elbows i knew my legs you got
the most legit halloween outfit i've
seen
well bro this is a real postal uh yeah
this [ __ ] is dude
that top is flying yeah man look at that
look at the hat this is a real hat
yeah bro i'm clean now yeah no it is a
clean outfit if dogs don't look down
stop talking edit that out can we edit
that out because
we keep that in mind this is a [ __ ]
like i said i was watching sportscenter
look how fat that [ __ ] was
that's pretty and then look what he got
to do you don't think we can make that
happen i think you know dude had a
triple chin
um i don't know if we can make it happen
we can
yeah straight dieting did you has your
boy come up with any plan yeah he has
well first of all what what is what are
we trying to do
okay we're trying to lose weight or what
is the challenge what's the challenge
who can lose the most weight by the end
of january
by the end of january so that's very
first yeah because i'm sitting here i
don't know what to say to him because
i was just like what is our challenge so
no november
so we'll start in november we'll start
november 1st so november through
february 1st so you can lose the most
november november 1st two so it's what
was that night so basically 90 days
90 day challenge 90 day fiance challenge
yeah
how much you weigh right now 260. okay
i'll be honest no we need the pictures
of the weight scale on instagram we
don't i trust them
no we can i'll we can do it you come to
the crib but i gotta give you gear
anyways
okay yeah so i'll come to the crib we'll
weigh in we'll weigh in we'll start from
that day
start from that day all right this is
chick-fil-a today
sure starts november first wherever you
want i just went on vacation so i'll
probably 261 i bet
yeah okay i'm probably like 250
something yeah oh
also i had a uh at 5 11. a quote
we both got to lose weight i know we
both got to lose weight but we can make
it happen
and on the road we have to hold each
other responding i think we could do it
yeah i think if we're together we'll be
fine yeah jay's trying to lose weight
too
so yeah yeah exactly yeah jay what and
eats eggs
yeah yeah yeah he [ __ ] he gets a he
gets food uh the groceries delivered
yeah he's gonna be cooking himself you
don't really eat bad no i don't the only
person that ain't bad is justin let's
just be honest
no i eat bad no doesn't eat a lot of
[ __ ] dude if you give me a reason to eat
battle you bet
oh same i'll be back same all right i
had a question since november 1st i'm
going nuts
i'm making my good ass chicken tongue
tonight oh for real
yeah we have to do it november 1st
because let me let me write halloween's
coming
yeah yeah saturday kids pizza party yeah
yeah no values excuse me november 1st
okay that's the challenge that is
november 1st monday
no it's sunday oh yeah because halloween
is on saturday so sunday
so sunday easy does it easy peasy
japanese yep mmm okay